[Music]
like the legend of the
Phoenix all ends with
[Music]
Beginnings what keeps the planet
spining the force of Love
[Music]
get we come too
far to give
her who we
are so let's raise the
bar and our
C to the
star I'm up all night to the sun he's up
all night to get sun I'm up all night
for good fun he's up all night to get
lucky we're up all night to the Sun
we're up all night to get some we're up
all night for good fun we're up all
night to get lucky we're up might to
gety we're up all might to gety we're up
night to gety we're up might
[Music]
to your present has
noon you gift keeps on
giving what is this I'm
feeling if you want to leave I'm
ready
oh cuz we come too
far to give
up who we
are so
let's raise the
bar in our
to the
start I'm up all night to the sun he's
up all night to get some I'm up all
night for good fun he's up all night to
get lucky we're up all night to the sun
we're up all night to get some we're up
all night for good fun we're up all
night to get okay we're up on night to
get lucky we're up on night to get lucky
we're up
to
[Music]
to oh we come too
far come to